madame la première ministre chers
collègues
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure madame la
première ministre nous sommes face à une
situation exceptionnelle et à des défis
immenses
une situation exceptionnelle d'abord par
la composition de notre assemblée le
peuple français à travers les élections
légistatives vient de faire de la
proportionnelle une réalité le groupe
démocrates attachés à l'idée d'une
représentation proportionnelle salue la
proposition notre présidente donc créé
ce principe dans le marbre de la loi au
cours de cette législature
de fait le parlement reflète davantage
aujourd'hui la société française dans la
diversité de ses opinions et de ses
attentes
loin d'être un signe d'instabilité
c'est une preuve de la vitalité intacte
de notre démocratie cela nous oblige à
réinventer notre façon de travailler
ensemble
chacun d'entre nous est à sa place ici
celle à laquelle l'a hissé le suffrage
universel avec les idées qu'ils
incarnent chacun
chacun a ici la lourde responsabilité
de façonner le destin de la france et
des français pour les cinq prochaines
années le parlement sera plus que jamais
au coeur de la vie politique et
institutionnelle
c'est un motif de satisfaction pour
notre famille politique
on est ce que je vais citer également
nous a appris que pour qu'on ne puisse
abuser du pouvoir il faut que par sa
disposition même le pouvoir arrête le
pouvoir
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 a
fait sien cet objectif et à donner
davantage de droits aux parlements dans
l'initiative et le contrôle législatif
elle a reconnu les droits de
l'opposition dont la présidence de la
commission des finances elle était
inspirée par l'inquiétude démocratique
d'un parlement qui ne refléteraient plus
l'opinion au musée leur l opposition au
point que celle-ci n'aurait d'autre
choix que la rue pour se faire entendre
nous avons la chance de disposer d'un
socle d'un socle institutionnel solide
qui permet d'inscrire le changement
politique majeur que nous vivons dans le
cadre existant le parlement devient
désormais incontournable ni une chambre
d'enregistrement ni un récif sur lequel
se brise toutes les réformes ou toutes
les idées
[Applaudissements]
il nous faudra revoir notre façon de
légiférer et de travailler ensemble
entre nous d'abord et avec le
gouvernement aussi dans un dialogue
constructif permettant d'aboutir à des
accords solide car viable dans le temps
et consentis par tous pour cela madame
la première ministre vous vous trouverez
toujours à vos côtés en qualité de
médiateur tout comme le groupe démocrate
nous avons élu la semaine dernière pour
la première fois une présidente de
l'assemblée nationale c'est une fierté
pour tous les parlementaires est un
signe incontestable que les mentalités
évoluent nous avons choisi pour la
première fois un député d'un parti qui
n'avait jamais gouverné la tête de la
commission des finances le gouvernement
ainsi remaniée est un gouvernement
d'action au service des français il
devra plus que jamais entendre ce qui se
dira dans notre assemblée et dans le
pays ses qualités d'écouté de dialogue
sont je le sais les vôtres madame la
première ministre et je salue votre
élection en tant que députée du calvados
qui fait de vous l'une des nôtres aussi
vous avez tout votre légitimité
vous êtes madame la première ministre
une femme d'état aguerris et je sais que
votre connaissance de nos institutions
et du gouvernement vous permettra de
conduire efficacement son action et
d'animer un dialogue vertueux avec le
parlement nous sommes en effet face à
des défis immenses il nous reviendra
ensemble de poursuivre les réformes
utiles à notre pays pour lesquels nos
concitoyens ont réélu le président de la
république et pour ce faire il nous
faudra continuer à libérer les énergies
sans casser les talons et réparer la
cohésion de notre société
le groupe démocrate est le premier
soutien de la majorité nous sommes
partageons les valeurs le respect de
chacun et le souhait d'une société plus
solidaire
le goût de la liberté dans une france
apaisée réunis autour du pacte
républicain avec un parlement fort et un
état de droit respecté le souci de voir
nos territoires protégés intégrer à la
république par une décentralisation
efficace maï et des services publics est
entendu dans leurs besoins spécifiques
le désir d'améliorer la vie des gens
dans le respect de l'état de droit de
moderniser l'économie
d'encourager les entrepreneurs et de
soutenir les plus fragiles contre les
chocs qui déstabilise la société la
volonté de répondre à l'urgence
climatique et préserver notre
environnement nous le devons aux
générations futures le haut conseil pour
le climat évalue l'augmentation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 6
4% depuis l'an dernier malgré une baisse
tendancielle de 23% par rapport à 1990
signe de l'importance de cette prise de
conscience au plus haut sommet de l'état
vous êtes madame la première ministre en
charge de la planification écologique
énergétique et vous avez déjà annoncé
nouvelle loi de programmation pour le
climat début 2000 23 c'est pourquoi nous
soutiendrons groupe démocrate le
programme ambitieux proposé par le
président de la république en matière
d'action climatique nous attacherons
avec vous à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 à rénover 700 mille
bâtiments à végétaliser les villes à
consacrer 10 milliards la transition
écologique sur le quinquennat
la défense de notre souveraineté
nationale aussi bien militaires que
stratégique énergétique et alimentaire
passe par une armée forte la
modernisation du modèle industriel et
agricole et le développement du mixte
énergétique
l'appartenance européenne qui nous
permet d'être plus forts ensemble sur la
scène internationale dans un contexte
qui a révélé la fragilité fragilité des
états isolé à ce titre nous pouvons nous
réjouir que nos partenaires et écouter
la voix la france au cours des six
derniers mois de présidence française de
l'union européenne
sur la scène internationale la france a
également oeuvré pour avancer sur les
questions climatiques le mois dernier le
jeu cet art pris l'engagement de mettre
un terme au financement des énergies
fossiles sans capture de carbone d'ici
la fin de l'année 2022 sous l'impulsion
du président la république
l'accord de paris a été réaffirmée il
vise à limiter le réchauffement
climatique à
1,5 pour cent par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle et à parvenir à zéro
émissions nettes carbone d'ici 2050 nous
aurons enfin l'impérieuse nécessité de
restaurer nos finances publiques très
dégradées pour ne pas léguer un avenir
hypothéqué à nos enfants sur ce point
nous devrons préserver les moyens de
l'état à faire face à une autre crise
majeure
les réponses ponctuelles et d'urgence
ont été adaptés à l'accueil ville 19
elles ont impliqué une dégradation
considérable de la dette l'état emprunte
aujourd'hui à 2% ce qui entraînera une
augmentation de 11 points de pib de la
dette en dix ans revenir à une maîtrise
réelle de nos finances est une
obligation
pas une option nous devrons réfléchir
aux solutions pérennes qui permettront
de re trouver un point d'équilibré
viable pour l'économie et la société
le monde change la france change la
société change notre pays divisé notre
devoir de tout faire pour réunir nos
concitoyens
cela nous oblige à un plus grand devoir
de solidarité et de responsabilité
la crise nous a montré la fragilité de
notre société d etat face aux crises
chacun d'entre nous l'a ressentie à son
propre niveau du retraité à l'étudiant
du chef d'entreprise aux salariés nous
devons donc renforcer notre capacité à
répondre à une nouvelle crise tout en
restaurant nos moyens de résilience
collectif à l'heure où l'inflation
aurait fait sur l'apparition frôlé les
6% sur l'année alors que les économistes
la croyait disparue à jamais nous devons
travailler en premier lieu sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat
pour nos concitoyens pour que chacun
puisse raisonnablement se projeter dans
l'avenir sans brider ni briser les
talents nous devront repenser la
fiscalité pour mieux répartir les
richesses et garantir l'accès aux
ressources naturelles et énergétiques
dans la rareté nous a été cruellement
rappelé nous devrons être collectivement
plus vertueux plus sobre plus économes
dans nos façons de vivre de consommer de
nous déplacer
nous devrons aussi accepté d'aborder
sans tabou la question du vieillissement
la société et ce qu'elle implique en
termes de cinquième risque
et de viabilité de notre système de
retraites ne pas le faire serait là
encore trahir les générations futures
nous vivons un contexte international de
montée des périls qui a déjà marqué de
sombres heures de l'histoire de notre
pays avec la guerre à nos portes en
europe dans l'eau l'horreur saisi chacun
de nous de nous nous nous devons tout
faire pour que la france se soit pas
déstabiliser et affronter aussi les
enjeux de la solidarité et de notre
tradition d'accueil désormais posée de
façon inédite les français ont besoin de
notre sagesse pas de posture politique
ou d'anathème madame la première
ministre
madame la première ministre le groupe
démocrate demeurera un soutien un
partenaire engagé à la fois au parlement
et dans votre gouvernement il sera le
laboratoire des pratiques nouvelles de
votre majorité
nous savons notre détermination nous
savons votre courage votre pugnacité
vous connaissez notre fidélité fidélité
notre soutien constructif c'est pourquoi
sur ce chemin vous avez toute notre
confiance je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]